H-I-I-T exercise is the best exercise for your heart, bar none.
So that means you're doing, you're basically doing intervals.
When I used to be in track, we'd run intervals, and I was in cross-country at track,
and you run as fast as you can for a period of time, you're running 400 meter intervals,
or 800 meter intervals, and then you have a period of rest that you go again,
and you go as hard as you possibly can.
That has been proven to be absolutely the best exercise for your heart,
because that's the exercise that you'd use to build blood vessels.
So that's what stimulates blood vessel production.
So it stimulates VAD-JF, so that's the vascular endothelial growth factor.
That's what stimulates that.
But the thing is, when you have cancer, you don't want to stimulate vascular endothelial growth factor.
I mean, that's you do not want to stimulate that, so I didn't even touch on that point,
but you're also, when you're doing that, working to exhaustion,
putting yourself in a completely anaerobic state, giving the cancer its feel to grow.
So you don't want to do that when you have a history of cancer.